sometimes Washington BB using enough you
also want to eat that laces fYI there's
movie recipes
today we're with chef RJ Cooper at five
Church in Atlanta Georgia
we've challenged him with making a dish
fit for Jurassic times chef Cooper's
chosen a list of essential ingredients
fit for a t-rex
they are audience tomahawk rib eye big
enough to satisfy any Jurassic appetite
potatoes not having them with steak is a
sin and broccoli raab because fiber is
our friend let's die in the soul
okay sorry just cook the food RJ
[Music]
okay Jurassic Park yeah one of the
biggest movies ever one of my favorite
movies oh wait I love the premise of it
obviously is what gets classic horror
movie types up right you go to a place
where there's no communication
whatsoever and there's monsters there
and the scope of this project film is
just unlike you had ever seen before
especially when they go you know and
they see the the field of all the
brontosaurus and all that stuff and
we're talking about that music that dad
oh man that when you're in that age and
you see that for the first time it just
like lit up your eyes yeah well and what
you get here that that subsequent
Jurassic movies start to lose but
Spielberg sort of brings to the table is
all the little touches right like the
mirror shot objects in mirror in here or
that famous things in the trailer with
the water jinglin is the t-rex bone
stored and you just be sure to lose that
as we move forward
[Music]
what do we think we might get here in
terms of the dish
oh I'm expecting something enormous well
there is that scene early in the movie
where he served them some kind of fish
in that room where Jeff Goldblum gets to
make his famous little kneeling speech
yeah I don't think that's where we're
going I didn't that like Chilean sea
bass or something that looks like
delayed feedback which is one of the
best fish ever
[Music]
apparently there's a picture of
Spielberg in front of the Triceratops
that looks like he has hunted and killed
it but the internet being the internet
there's like legit outraged by people
who are too ignorant to realize that
there's a picture okay you do that
Jeremy well it's just people were doing
this age now where people are blind to
be affected and so it doesn't take
anything more than a which push them
okay yeah yeah fine
I will say this and we didn't really
touch on that is that that's how good
the effects on effexor and runnable fam
Lanson amazing and if you're used to a
bunch of movies from the 90's and you
finally hit Jurassic Park you're like
whoa yeah
did this really get made in 1993 yeah
because it it's a mixture of animatronic
and digital but the digital is amazing
well L because any animatronics in
Jurassic world that we had I mean it's
hardly any notice that everything looks
too perfect to look real in that movie
whereas there's something about the
original that just feels feels real yeah
there's like those things are actually
there yeah when he's like you know
resting on the Triceratops and yeah that
breath and everything you see his eyes
just getting you you know when the t-rex
is outside the car or kids are in and
he's like eyeballing enough clothes or
whatnot I mean I believe that thing is
really there
[Music]
holy God what the I'm not a god I'm just
so you grew a dinosaur and killed it
and bloom yo let me go so you know
nothing better than Jurassic Park in the
Jurassic steak right so this is a 48
ounce public 50-60 day dry cured Oh
prime beef CA B then I take them and I
take all our wagons fat from the
Kagoshima k5 vigor that we get whoa and
I take it all the fat and I bury it like
coffee
Oh is there an age is in the fat so we
did was we just season it with thyme and
rosemary black pepper and salt and
roasted in the heart with wood we've got
kind of that smoking on a cool flavor
what is this on the top there so this is
the butter as we make with reduced
Cabernet wool shallots and enfold in
bone marrow so yeah this dish needs a
little bit more fat and just in things
that I would be with it fingerling
potatoes we've been competing olive oil
and herbs Oh Cipollini onions that are
like splutter broccoli rabe Justin you
know you need something to push that
drill you heard I mean then you're
trying to kill me before we're gonna
have to deal with a I'm digging in this
is amazing you've never heard about
aging in wagang fast
yeah that's new to me and all that all
it is this flavor it's tenderize me just
like duck confit or anything it's just
going to preserve what it is I mean
think about what reservation was back in
It's A Wrap eight times we would salt
smoked and then and I how long you been
cooking I've been cooking since I was 16
in 32 years Wow
and when did you figure out this is
definitely what I want to do for I have
not figured that out yet really still
thinking about you know going to your
lawyer it's it's a lifestyle you know
when you get to the level that we cook
it you know and you win all the oculars
it's a lifestyle thing it's not a job
the crooks on the steak
um you're killing me what does I mean I
know you said you put black pepper and
cold exact timing rosemarys he means the
bone marrow butter is killing me man
yeah man it's really good stuff I have
to say thank you for doing all my fellow
we really appreciate it it was weekend
awesome unbelievable
you guys take your crack killers before
you like spit every I got a badge on
there I gave you my backpack valid dad
about two o'clock yeah
thanks to our Jane the folks at five
Turks for the journey back in time make
sure you head over to the community
table channel to hear more from him and
other amazing chefs we've gotten to hang
out with thanks for watching and we'll
see you next time on movie recipes
[Music]